>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay, and
one thing I want to get,
because you have such an arc.
I want to get to your
visuals early on.
There he is.
[ Applause ]
So I'm always fascinated
with origin stories
of the creators behind
their creations,
because cartoonists are
often a different animal.
I think that the political
cartoonist, Jack Ohman,
once said like "Meeting a
cartoonist is like a little bit
like meeting a weekend weather man.
You know they exist, but meeting
them sort of in real life,
it's like how did you get that job?
Or what was, you know?"
But most cartoonists I know wanted,
as children, to be cartoonists,
and they're the ones that
actually, though, had the skill.
Did you always want
to be a cartoonist?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, I wanted
to be a cartoonist starting probably
in maybe second or third grade.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
what were you reading?
>> Lincoln Peirce: I
was reading Peanuts.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, of course.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Of course.
And I was reading, -- we got two
daily newspapers at my house.
One came in the morning.
One came in the afternoon.
So I read the comics in the
Boston Globe in the morning,
and in the afternoon,
I read the comics
in the Foster's Daily Democrat.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay, were you
living in New Hampshire at the time?
>> Lincoln Peirce: In
New Hampshire, yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: And when did
you start drawing your creations?
[ Laughing ]
>> Lincoln Peirce: You know, I mean,
I think there's a difference
between,
you know, copying and drawing.
So I started copying when I was
probably five or six years old,
and I think I copied for probably
a couple of years, you know?
Just copying -- like I
would draw Charlie Brown.
I'd draw Snoopy.
I draw Andy Capp, Fred Bassett.
You know, all these comic strips.
Even if I didn't necessarily
like the comments,
I might like the way they look.
>> Michael Cavna: Something
about the visual was appealing.
>> Lincoln Peirce:
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So here you've got the progression.
It's a school performance
right there.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And there.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: So that's
school picture day and I always,
when I talk to kids, because I do
school visits, and I talk to kids,
and I say that Nate
is not a bad kid.
He is a good kid, to which
bad things oftentimes happen.
Like a really disastrous school
picture day like that one.
>> Michael Cavna: Real good kid to
home bad things happened growing up,
or a bad kid to whom
good things happened?
>> Lincoln Peirce: No,
a good kid, and I think,
and the overall spectrum, I
mean, I wanted to be a bad kid.
Bad kids are having all the fun.
>> Michael Cavna: Sure.
>> Lincoln Peirce: The bad kids, you
know, if you acted out in elementary
or middle school, and a
teacher really screamed
at you, you were a legend.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: You are a
legend, and so I always sort
of envied those kids, but I
was never quite bold enough
to really act out in a way that I
knew would disappoint my parents.
>> Michael Cavna: Know, I heard
John Purse never acted out either.
>> Lincoln Peirce: He did not.
He did not.
So I had that sort of that
envy of the bad kids, but no,
I was pretty much a good kid.
>> Michael Cavna: You
were a good kid.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Right.
>> Michael Cavna: Can
we go back one?
I think I clicked too far.
So there you get a sense of Nate.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, so that's
a Sunday page, and I -- it has --
it's got like a pratfall in it.
Like it's got slapstick in it,
which is one of the things I love,
and it has something -- what I think
you can do certain things in comics
that you can't do it other media.
You know, like from
one panel to the next,
you can imply that like
five minutes have gone
by without saying five
minutes later.
So in this one, you know that a
significant amount of time passes
from the second to the
last panel to the last one.
Enough time for Nate to go
flying up and climb in a tree
and have the lifeguard have to, you
know, or to climb up to get him.
And so -- but it's funnier
if you don't show all
that; I think it's funnier.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, absolutely.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: Absolutely.
And so here we get to
see Nate, you know --
>> Lincoln Peirce: He's talking
about his learning style,
which he describes as
stop, drop, and roll.
Yeah, I just like that -- I just
thought stop, drop, and roll.
That's a phrase that all
kids know, and just a staple
in my comic strip is Nate
sort of experiencing things
in different ways from the way
other people do, and so for him,
that's sort of a perfect --
you know, that's a phrase that
is completely like emblematic
of his whole philosophy
and his coping skills.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
his method of survival.
That could have been.
That was the alternate title
of the strip, wasn't it?
Was stop, drop, and roll?
>> Lincoln Peirce:
It could have been.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So here you were talking about
Peanuts being an influence here.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yes.
>> Michael Cavna: So here
we see from your sketchbook.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, so my
mother, bless her heart, you know,
she -- so I got an allowance
at the time, one dollar a week.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And those Peanuts
little paperbacks cost 50 cents.
So if I didn't spend my money on
anything else, I could buy two
of those in a week,
and I bring them home,
and my mother would immediately
write our name and the date in them.
Like probably because she --
she did that with everything.
I mean, she wrote that
on my underwear.
I mean, you know, like
as if I was going
to leave my underwear
lying around somewhere.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, well, if
you stopped, dropped, and rolled,
and something had happened --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
right, you never know.
And then once she had written
the name and the date text
of the book was mine to do with
what I wanted, and what I wanted
to do a lot of time was
try to draw the characters.
So yeah, that's my -- I had a
problem with feet back then.
I hadn't mastered that yet.
But yeah, that's Charlie Brown.
He's carrying Snoopy's
supper dish out to Snoopy.
>> Michael Cavna: I love it.
Now you were first syndicated by
NEA, which was a division of United,
and of course, Charles "Sparky"
Schulz basically helped to --
United was the house
that he helped build.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Absolutely.
>> Michael Cavna: Did you ever
get a chance to meet Sparky?
>> Lincoln Peirce: I met him, yeah.
I actually -- our first contact
was we spoke on the phone,
because back then the comics editor
was a woman named Sarah Gillespie,
and when you are a new
cartoonist, sometimes,
not always from what I understand,
but sometimes she would show the
work of new cartoonists to Sparky.
>> Michael Cavna: Yes.
>> Lincoln Peirce: It's so
she showed my strip to Sparky,
and then she said, she said,
"You might be getting
a call from Sparky."
And I said wow.
And then some time went by,
and then one day, my wife
and I were still living in
Brooklyn, and the phone rang.
My wife answered the phone.
I remember I was lying on
the couch in the living room,
and my wife came in, and she said
Charles Schulz is on the phone.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
and it was, you know,
I was talking to my boyhood hero.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And we
talked for like an hour,
and then we talked,
you know, not often.
We weren't like close friends
by any means, but we talked once
or twice a year, and then I met him
in person for the one and only time
in 1996 at The Ruben New York.
>> Michael Cavna: Sure, yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And I attached
myself to him and monopolized him
as best I could, because how
often do you get a chance
to speak to your hero?
>> Michael Cavna: Did you
ask him how to draw feet?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
he was very helpful there.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, I
met him two years later.
I was so busy kissing his feet
that I couldn't draw the -- yeah.
You know, that's amazing.
It's something about --
there was such a fraternity
in the comics industry that you
find yourself meeting your heroes,
and that special thing.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
there's nothing like it.
It's great.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
yeah, so here,
you have the evolution
of you as a cartoonist.
>> Lincoln Peirce: This is my first
original comic strip creation,
Super Jimmy.
>> Michael Cavna: How old were
you, do you think, when you --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Probably 10.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay,
did your mom date this?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Well, as you can
tell -- you know, so, of course,
I was a huge comics reader,
and I loved the funny comics,
but I also loved the
action ones, and I loved --
you know, I heard Roz
mention Mad Magazine.
So I love those sort of
parities and satires.
So my thought was,
I create a superhero
who combines all the things I love.
He's funny, but he has superpowers.
So, you know, he's a superhero
who is not very bright, basically,
and just makes everything worse.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, I love --
so, and then you have
your progression.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, so,
the character on the left,
the fellow with the blond
hair, his name is Nate,
and the guy on the
right is named Marty.
So this submission was
the precursor to Big Nate.
It was a comic strip
called Neighborhood Comics,
and it was based on my
childhood and the neighborhood
in New Hampshire where I grew up.
With the younger brother, me,
and the older brother, Nate.
Nate is my nickname
for my older brother.
>> Michael Cavna: This is
a more suave looking Nate,
a more polished-looking Nate.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, well, so
I sent this in, and they told me,
you know, the spiky blond
hair, he looks a little bit
like Calvin from Calvin and Hobbes.
You know, and of course, as a
cartoonist, the last thing you want
to be told is, you know,
your character looks too
much like another character.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: So I went
back to the drawing board
and I redesigned Nate
in a fairly radical way.
So I think in the next
slide, it might show --
>> Michael Cavna: And you dodged the
lion you had in there, too, maybe?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Exactly,
all right, so there's Nate,
the pudgy guy on the right.
Yeah, that's Nate.
>> Michael Cavna: That's
a massive makeover.
>> Lincoln Peirce: That
was a huge makeover.
So parents and people of a certain
age will back me up on this.
During the late 1980s, there was an
unfortunate hair trend among young
men where it was sort of
long on the top and almost
like shaved all around the sides.
It look like a mushroom cap.
So I gave Nate hair like that,
and I made him overweight,
because I didn't want him to
look like Calvin or anybody else.
And then I got more
feedback from the woman
who eventually became my editor,
and she said, "Now Nate looks
like an overweight,
middle-aged man."
You know? He looks
like Peter Griffin
up there or something like that.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
so you've gone from Calvin
to Peter Griffin in one makeover.
So the progression continues.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
so then I started --
so that drawing is
probably from a year
or two before the strip
finally got up and running.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay.
And the top one is his
dad and not Nate, right?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
well, you know, like I said.
He sees and experiences
things in ways.
You know, so his dad has may be like
a tiny potbelly, a slight potbelly,
but Nate imagines him as being
this enormous, you know, like --
>> Michael Cavna: Oompa
Loompa type --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Right, right.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
And even the spikiness evolved,
where Nate now has those
polished sort of --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, he still
bawled on the sides, and inevitably,
I go into school visits, and almost
always asked about Nate's hair.
Like what's up with it?
You know? I've been asked why
does Nate have dreadlocks?
I've been asked why is
he bawled on the sides?
I've been asked, you know, were you
imitating other partially bald comic
strip characters, like
Charlie Brown?
>> Michael Cavna: I was going
to say Charlie Brown, Sparky,
just why is your child
almost completely bald?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Exactly,
exactly, and I don't quite know why
but that's just the way -- I wanted,
after they had told me he looks
too much like a middle-aged man.
I said, well, I've got to
make him younger, and spiky,
sort of wild hair seemed
like the way to go.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
and any cartoonist,
random acts of baldness
is always amusing.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: So
you again -- yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Right.
I just, you know, so just to
contrast, you know, the last drawing
and this one were probably
separated by over 20,
maybe 20 or 20-some years.
So one thing I talk to kids
about all the time is, you know,
you're never too old to improve.
I mean, I could not draw all
that well when I started.
You know, even when
I got syndicated,
in my first several years
that the strip was out there,
I look at those strips now,
I really, I kind of cringe.
I don't like the way they look.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: But I can draw
well enough now that, you know,
I can make the strip look
the way I want it to look.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
yeah, enough control.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: You know, and
speaking of launching the strip,
I know that you launched it about
the same time as Dilbert, and --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
he was a little before me.
>> Michael Cavna: A little
before, but Scott Adams talked
about he was his strip originally
to be very much a more home-based.
Have Dilbert be 80% in the
home and 20% workplace,
until his readers said, no,
here's where the heat is.
Here's where you're funny is.
You didn't -- you had a
different orientation originally
for your strip.
Can you talk about that?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, so I
thought it was going to do a strip.
First of all, there were a lot of
comic strip families at the time,
sort of conventional family
units, a couple of parents,
a couple of kids, you
know like Foxtrot.
For Better or for Worse,
Calvin and Hobbes, you know?
So I said well, I've got to
be different, so I said, well,
Nate will have like a
single-parent home with a dad.
And so I thought, well, I can
probably write a lot of good gags
about this single dad sort of
like a hapless guy, overwhelmed.
You know, maybe he'll
try to date people
and you'll have these two
sort of rambunctious kids.
So I thought it was going to
do sort of a domestic strip.
And then I realized
in pretty short order
that I wasn't all that
interested in that.
That I was interested in school.
Like school gags, teachers,
you know,
the stuff that happens in school.
Schools are hilarious.
You know?
>> Michael Cavna: That's
where the funny is.
That's where the funny is.
So you launched stepping
out in 120 and then 135.
>> Lincoln Peirce:
Yeah, at the time,
it was the most successful launch
they had had in a long, long time,
and then it completely
went down in flames.
>> Michael Cavna: Can you
talk about how that -- that --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yep, I can.
So there was a -- so comic
strips are sold by a sales staff,
and they are divided into
regions of the country.
>> Michael Cavna: Sometimes
they're offered bonuses, right?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Sometimes
they are offered bonuses,
and so United Media really wanted
to make a splash with Big Nate.
And so they offered a
bonus for the sales staff
to see how many papers
you can sell Nate into,
and so the West Coast sales rep
sold Nate into a lot of papers, yes,
but also fabricated a lot of things,
so that he could collect his bonus.
>> Michael Cavna: So you have
your hope building like --
I know when this same
syndicate launched me,
you would get like this rep.
They just sold in LA.
And you get these reports back.
So you must have been like,
wow, I'm going like hotcakes.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And back
then, it all happened by mail.
So I'm getting these sales receipts
saying you've just been sold
into the Chicago Tribune.
You've just been sold into
the LA Times or whatever,
and I was absolutely elated.
You know, I thought
my ship has come in.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce:
And then suddenly,
and this was all even before the
strip started showing up in papers,
and then I started
getting other envelopes.
And they were slips that
were a different color,
and they were cancellations.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: So the sales rep
who had done this, he actually died,
literally within days of the strip
debuting, and like all the sales
that he had made up, obviously,
went away, and a lot of the sales
that were legitimate went away,
because he wasn't there
to follow them up.
>> Michael Cavna: Sure, wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: So I lost, in the
first year I was syndicated I lost,
I think, over half my papers.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh,
oh, that's brutal.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And my editor
had told me like you might lose 10
or 15% of the papers that
you get, but that's normal.
That's fine.
>> Michael Cavna: Not 50%.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Not 50.
Not 50. So, but it survived.
>> Michael Cavna: Did you go to the
funeral of that West Coast salesman?
>> Lincoln Peirce: I
sent a big bouquet.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay.
Okay, wow, so here we have --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, that's
the first Big Nate daily ever.
>> Michael Cavna: It's
looking polished already.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Not to me.
I mean, I look at it, and I
mean, visually, in some ways,
you can tell he's the
same character,
but he looks very different.
You know, he's lankier.
He's skinnier.
He's taller.
>> Michael Cavna: I was going to
say he had more of the Bigfoot style
of cartooning with
the long legs and --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, huge feet.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, yeah, so --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
so that was the first one,
and this is another strip from the
very first week, when I, you know --
this is sort of indicative
of the sort
of gag I thought I might do a
lot of, with like his family,
these family conversations.
>> Michael Cavna: And you're still
even visually working out the size
of the balloons and the characters.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yep,
I'm working it all out.
I mean, I knew that I always wanted
to do just the four-panel strip.
I love the rhythm of four panels.
So I've never done a daily
that was not four panels.
I've never liked changed to three.
I just like it.
I like four.
But you know, can we go back to
that last one just for a second.
>> Michael Cavna: Can you go back?
>> Lincoln Peirce: So
humbling moment here.
So just to show, to show
like that I -- oh, yeah.
I like that gag too.
But if we can't get --
if we can't get back
to the last one, that's fine.
But Nate has this older
sister, Ellen,
and so I was showing this
early strip to someone,
and he looked at Ellen, and he said,
"Who' is the kid in
the coonskin cap?"
And I said that's her hair.
And you know, I could
not draw well enough.
I've always had trouble with hair.
Hair is hard to draw, and
that was how poorly I drew.
I drew so poorly that someone
would look at this drawing of Ellen
and mistake her hair
curve for a coonskin cap.
So I had a long, long way to go.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
this is Nate and his --
and Gina, the girl
that sits behind him.
His tormentor.
>> Michael Cavna: His
tormentor, sure.
And more babes.
>> Lincoln Peirce: This is the
only Big Nate book in existence
for like the first 18 or
19 years of my career.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: I had one book.
It didn't sell at all, and
the strip was not, you know,
it was sort of moderately
successful, but not really.
And like every cartoonist I've
ever met, I thought, my God.
If only I could find a way
to get my strip in front
of more people, especially kids.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
also, it's incredibly tough.
It's one thing for four, five, six
years to figure I'm going to stay
in the same client
list and all that.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Right.
>> Michael Cavna: Now for 18 years,
you know, how do you maintain?
Because you have to
be very inner directed
about I'm just true
to what I'm creating.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, well, there
are bills to be paid, you know?
So you have no choice, but I
would oscillate back and forth.
At times, I would really feel sorry
for myself and think, you know,
I know that this is better than,
you know, like it should be
in more papers, and then
on the other hand, I think,
what my complaining about?
I'm making a living as a cartoonist.
My childhood dream.
You know? And as a kid I used
to think, I would be happy
if I could get a strip in
my parents' hometown paper.
That would be good enough for me.
So why am I complaining about
not being in enough papers?
And I'd go back and
forth between those two.
>> Michael Cavna: No, but the
joy to get to do it for a living,
I would draw coonskin caps for the
rest of my life if that would --
so this leads to, how many
people here know Jeff Kinney,
the creator of Diary of a Wimpy Kid?
Not personally but -- so
there's a lesson, a moralness,
which if you create anything
and you get fan mail,
always answer your fan mail.
So can you talk about a young
Jeff Kinney reaching out to you?
>> Lincoln Peirce:
Yeah, what the time,
he was a very young Jeff Kinney.
I think he was 19 or 20.
>> Michael Cavna: He was here at the
University of Maryland, I believe.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yep, and
he was doing a comic strip
for The Diamondback.
>> Michael Cavna: Yes.
>> Lincoln Peirce:
And he sent letters
to several syndicated
cartoonists, or their advice,
and this was not his first letter to
me, but his second, and he wrote me,
and I wrote him back, and
we sort of became pen pals.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, yeah,
it looks like your mom
dated it, by the way.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And we maintained
this letter writing correspondence
for a couple of years.
Basically, until he graduated
from college, and that he went
on with his life, and
we sort of lost touch,
but he always was incredibly
gracious, you know, in thanking me
for whatever sort of --
because he would ask advice
about trying to break in.
At the time, you know, he wanted
to be a syndicated cartoonist.
>> Michael Cavna: That
was still the dream.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
that was the dream.
>> Michael Cavna: Very much so.
Yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And there he is.
>> Michael Cavna: There's Jeff.
>> Lincoln Peirce:
A happy-looking guy.
>> Michael Cavna: A
very happy looking guy.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And so
years pass, and I am looking
at the Boston Globe, a newspaper
that I still subscribe to,
and I saw little thing down --
you know, a little advertisement
that said, "Diary of a
Wimpy Kid," and you know,
about an author signing and
reading at a bookstore in Boston.
And I saw the artwork
before I saw the name.
I said, that looks
like Jeff's stuff.
And then I saw his
name, Jeff Kinney.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And
I said, he wrote a book.
This is tremendous.
And at the time, this was
before the Wimpy Kid --
this was his first book, and it
was just starting to get traction.
So I tracked him down, I said,
Jeff, you know, congratulations.
We got back in touch, and he,
long story short, he helped me.
He said he had all those
years remained a big Nate fan.
And he said you should
have a book deal.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
Wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: And he was
growing his at this point
to a half billion dollar enterprise.
>> Lincoln Peirce:
He was in the process
of becoming the 500-pound
gorilla of children's publishing.
So that's a good guy
to have on your side.
>> Michael Cavna: So answer that
fan mail, because you never know.
Wait 18 years.
>> Lincoln Peirce:
So I got my book deal
to start writing children's
chapter books.
These books, really,
because of Jeff Kinney.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
and he really helped kind
of readers rediscover and
reinvigorate that entire,
what I would call the
hybrid novel, right?
Where you have the
prose and the pictures.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Right, you
know, he says that he was writing
that first Wimpy kid
book for adults,
to look back on their childhood
in sort of a nostalgic way.
He didn't even realize,
at first, he was writing
like the perfect kids' book.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And of
course, that lined notebook paper,
that's a motif that I had used
in the early days of Big Nate.
>> Michael Cavna: I
was going to say --
>> Lincoln Peirce: So, of course,
when I got back in touch with him,
I said you'll hear from my lawyers.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
[ Laughing ]
>> Lincoln Peirce: And so he said,
you'll hear from my accountants.
>> Michael Cavna: And
you worked it out.
>> Lincoln Peirce: But no, I
mean, he and another author
and cartoonist, who is
here today, Dave Pilkey.
>> Michael Cavna: Sure,
Captain Underpants.
>> Lincoln Peirce: You know, both
those guys have really, I mean,
really, before those guys, if you
went into a school library and asked
for a book that had comics in it,
the librarian would say sorry.
You know, it's going
to be old Peanuts.
It's not going to be --
>> Michael Cavna: If that.
If that.
>> Lincoln Peirce: If that, yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: So because you
drew lined paper all those years
earlier, and he --
>> Lincoln Peirce: Exactly, yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: And he creates
this, and so suddenly, now,
you have your own publishing
franchise.
>> Lincoln Peirce: I do, yeah.
So I did eight of these novels,
which are different for me
from the strip, because
I write the strip
for everybody, for
readers of all ages.
So I had to sort of learn.
I write the books for kids.
You know, ages basically
7 to 12 or so.
And so it's a different kind
of writing, but I ended up --
I didn't know if I'd like it or not.
But I really liked it.
So I did eight of them, and
I thought eight is good.
>> Michael Cavna: Eight is good.
Eight is enough, as it were.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: So this is,
I don't know if anyone
hasn't seen the books.
This is what they look like inside.
So I think sometimes I'm a little
mystified sometimes when I go
into bookstores, and I see some
of the books I see are
advertised as graphic novels.
They're really not graphic novels.
I don't do graphic novels.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
these are hybrid.
>> Lincoln Peirce: These are --
but they're not illustrated
books either.
So that's why I like the
name hybrid for them,
because they combine
the text and the comics.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, it did
you find yourself playing --
you know, each creator who work --
does these hybrids seems to play
with text and picture and how their
own balance, and also, some of them,
I know, aim at like 6th
grade boys and girls.
They're trying to figure out
what is their sweet spot.
Did you kind of play with your
own balance levels, if you will?
>> Lincoln Peirce: I just think,
like I call myself a rhythm writer.
So when I write, I just hear
the dialogue in my head.
I hear what the kids are saying,
and just the rhythm has to be right.
And it just suggests to me like
well, this I can just write in text.
But this line, it's got to be
a speech bubble or you've got
to have a visual to
go along with this.
So I can't really do find
it any better than that,
but I think a good rule of thumb
with kids is, you know,
show not tell.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: And they love
-- it's like, if you're going to --
what's funnier for a kid?
Reading a description of
someone getting hit in the face
with a pie, or seeing it happen?
>> Michael Cavna: Well, you opened
with pratfalls and
FOOMs and all that.
So you came back to it.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, and so what
about Sandy and the Surfriders?
>> Lincoln Peirce: Well, I picked
this, because one of the joys
of writing these chapter
books for me was
that I could be more ambitious
with the artwork, and you know,
more than I could with the strip.
And so I could never do a drawing
like this in the comic strip,
but in a book, I could, and this
is also the reason the books took a
year to do, because these
drawings take a long time,
and I don't draw all that fast.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
but -- and let's just see.
We're running out in there.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah,
and so those are compilations
of the comic strip.
That's a sketchbook page.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
I love how that looks.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Those
are my tools of the trade.
I'm very low-tech.
I don't do anything digitally.
Just paper.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
Sparky's same tools, right?
You haven't changed.
>> Lincoln Peirce: That's my
favorite review of all time.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, yeah.
Was that from -- that's
not from your editor?
>> Lincoln Peirce: That is from
the son of a Harper Collins editor.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Who read the
first Big Nate chapter book,
and that was his review.
"Big Nate is going to
blow your pants off."
>> Michael Cavna: Wow, wow, that
could have gone on the cover.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, we used it.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
and then you get your own.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Well,
this is a creepy plush toy.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Lincoln Peirce: So you never
know how people's Big Nate fandom is
going to manifest, and I found this,
and I've had nightmares
about it ever since.
>> Michael Cavna: I am now.
He's alive.
He's frightening.
>> Lincoln Peirce: I
think it's the feet.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, oh
yeah, it always comes back,
and in the Netherlands where
it's [Dutch spoken] right?
>> Lincoln Peirce:
Yeah, [Dutch spoken].
>> Michael Cavna: I am Grute.
>> Lincoln Peirce: So a
lot of different languages.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh, yeah, and you
have the whole team here speaking
at Dave Pilkey and you and
Jeff Kinney and Stephan Pastis.
So you guys are all killing it on
the bookshelves and the bookstores.
>> Lincoln Peirce: Yeah, that's
from a fundraiser we did,
and what an honor and a privilege
to hang out with those guys.
>> Michael Cavna: And none of them
really draws a full head of hair.
>> Lincoln Peirce: I know.
I know.
>> Michael Cavna: I mean
he doesn't even try,
Dave Pilkey, with Captain
Underpants.
So yeah, there's a
common thread there.
Well, this is, you
know, congratulations,
because you are just a
tremendous storyteller.
Your characters come alive, not in
a creepy way like that plush toy,
but please give a big
hand to Lincoln Peirce.
[ Applause ]
>> Lincoln Peirce: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.